il y a des jours comme ça où la foule
décide de prendre un bain de foule
c'est un peu comme si les supporters
n'avaient pas quitté les champs-elysées
depuis le sacre de leur île
cette année
bien sûr ils sont venus voir les joueurs
mais finalement après sa nuit folle le
peuple de paris créé son propre
on est des joueurs après deux heures
d'attentes au soleil ils ne verront donc
toute façon qu'un petit bout de fait un
tout petit moment parfois au prix de
beaucoup d'efforts
laurent blanc qui porte en coupe coupe
et c'est la police on le sent le but
voit pas grand chose en fait ouais il a
brandi la la force plutôt le petit comme
disent les sportifs s'est traduite aussi
à l'applaudimètre mais qui donc est
alors préféré et comme d'habitude c'est
aux anciens de donner la leçon de
mathématiques modernes et d'un et de
fait trois communes bien le milieu de
terrain de brésiliens a dit des
supporters français qui sont des taux
est peut-être at-il raison
la première nouveauté
en général il ya une heure ils ont
quitté progressivement l'arc de leur
criant presque à regret à chacun d'entre
eux maintenant de vérifier si la grande
histoire du foot a changé la leur à eux
d'écrire leur propre bonheur